this is great that's me
[Applause]
just be kind of unity I made a vow to
love you faithfully you're the night
you're the color of my
you're the Cure you're the pain you're
the comfort you in times of need
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her and to keep you safe how the hell
are you Anna
Jack what do you want first long as we
both shall live
listen can I hear it
[Music]
good morning wife
[Music]
this is great look out your window no
I'm taking you away for the weekend I
just can't believe this is my life then
I get to live with you
that meant nothing to me before you had
a great office we wanted to welcome the
new fiction editor I bought it for us I
should have asked you first
oh my god Christian this is Jim Matteo
the architect this location is perfect
I'm going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking of my husband as if
I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.
grey I'll pick you up at 5:00 that may
not be done by vain
we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what do you want
so you want to play yes sir
I made a vow to love you faithfully
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her
to comfort you in times of need and to
keep you safe first long as we both
shall live
turns apart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]